of course we're starting in ukraine with
a warning of increased violence and new
allegations of unthinkable cruelty and
unthinkable is a word here this footage
shows a massive column of russian troops
heading toward the eastern part of the
country ahead of what could be a major
new offensive right now russia appears
to be primarily focused on taking more
territory in the east the poor city the
port city of mariupol may soon fall
under their control after a campaign
that the city's mayor says has killed
more than 10 thousand civilians the u.s
is also monitoring a local ukrainian
military report that chemical weapons
have been used in marijuana so far those
claims have not been verified by cbs
news
holly williams is in ukraine with we
should warn you once again this is a
very upsetting story involving
accusations of sexual assault by
russian-led forces holly good morning to
you
good morning gail well there have been
multiple allegations of rape by russian
forces during this invasion the
ukrainian military took us to a village
that on the surface appeared relatively
unscathed even though locals said
russian forces had seized control there
for two weeks but hidden from sight was
a story of horrendous sexual violence
and we want to we want to warn you that
our report is deeply disturbing
vera is 83 years old a retired school
teacher who told us when her village was
occupied by russian forces last month
she was raped
he grabbed me by the back of my neck she
said i started to choke i couldn't
breathe
vera told us she was attacked in her own
home with her disabled husband in the
house
she said she was also beaten during her
ordeal
i told the one who raped me i'm old
enough to be your mother would you let
this happen to your mother vera said
he made me shut up
the spring has arrived in ukraine and
the russians have left this village also
they dug themselves in here but there's
no celebration
vera told us she feels neither dead nor
alive
when he finished he grabbed a bottle of
vodka she said
i asked if i could put my clothes back
on he barked no
she told us when he left he fired his
assault rifle in the air three times
outside
the ukrainian military took us to vera's
village because they'd heard reports of
sexual assault by russian forces we were
told others were also raped here
including a 16 year old girl
we cannot independently verify any of
the allegations but vera's story was
detailed compelling and heartbreaking
she's also reported it to the ukrainian
police she told us who took sheets away
for testing
i wish he'd killed me instead of what he
did fiera said
she told us she believes her attacker
was from ukraine's far east a region
controlled by russian-backed separatists
where men have reportedly been
conscripted to fight for russia
even now they've gone pushed back by the
ukrainian military vera is visibly
anxious
i feel like they're going to break into
my house at night i jump at every noise
she said
every night i'm petrified
ukrainian war crimes investigators are
documenting alleged atrocities and the
united nations says it's increasingly
hearing of rape and sexual violence here
in ukraine but war crimes are
notoriously difficult to prosecute
gail
holly i don't even know what to say 83
years old that's about as disgusting as
i've ever heard
thank you
for that story